now i'm gonna get really spiritual with
you
i have to speak with like my guides my
angels my spirit guides just to make
sure that it aligns
i asked for
how do you find a good story
i get pitched every day all day
everywhere everyone has a story
i get
submissions through talent management
companies talent agents
while i'm at a film festival
people that are not in the business
as well
and
it's just
comes to me all the time i want to say
if
i'm at a film festival or event i'm
constantly hearing pitches and i mean
i'm doing the same too pitching as well
i i feel that for mainly industry events
probably for the most part that's
probably what i pay attention to like if
it comes out of
um
like a project i found was out of focus
london uh during uh the end of 2020 on
zoom where i met this filmmaker and he
shared this incredible story and i was
like wow that's really interesting like
let me learn more you know um
and uh i meet with a lot of reps so
they tell me about their talent they ask
me what i'm looking to make what i'm
looking to do
so
i look at
who they work with um
and look at their work or if i go to a
film festival and i see a film that i
really enjoy
then i'll approach the filmmaker
um
and maybe networking events sometimes
when i attend them uh it's been a mixed
bag how i've found material or
um
come on to projects
sure and you've written one at least one
yourself right a short film
um
i i wrote a short that i never made um
i have um
maybe collaborated you know in terms of
story you know with the shorts that i've
made in the past feature-wise i haven't
done any of that
um and i'm actually writing something
with a writing partner now
on
a project
but traditionally i'm not a writer
that's not my my lane
how much does your intuition factor into
choosing whether to say yes to a story
not the project or the people attached i
know you said that's important
but what if they're amazing people and
you know you'd work great with them but
you're not sure about the story
um
i mean my intuition is very important uh
it definitely is a major decision maker
on that
um
and i'll have to sit with it with myself
you know i'll have to meditate to it
and now i'm gonna get really spiritual
with you
i have to speak with like my guides my
angels my spirit guides just to make
sure that it aligns um i ask for
a sign you know whatever that is that
sign can be someone
saying something or me reading something
or me reading a license plate or you
know i ask for signs for alignment for
it to make sense
uh for it to be proper in my trajectory
and what i'm looking to make and do
when did you know that your intuition
would never let you down
how old were you
uh probably recently i want to say
within the past uh
maybe
six years or so it got really stronger
like i've always worked in my intuition
but say since 2016
is um it got really strong i was in uh
i went to istanbul
besides everyone telling me not to go
because uh it got a little um
dangerous around that time period i was
in between two uh
uh bombings uh while was in istanbul
and even though uh this happened
um i was in a
place of
bliss
and happiness and i felt like i had a
strong awakening
um while i was out there um there's
nothing that i did specifically it was
just the sense of
uh the vibration and the energy and the
frequency that i was at
and i just fine-tuned it
over the years
and just really believing in myself
and doing work on myself and having the
confidence in myself um so i'd say from
2016 from that moment from that trip
maybe even earlier in the year but that
trip it became very strong um and then
it just got stronger and stronger where
i just knew
myself were you working on a film in
turkey
no i just had gone my i had this my soul
was telling me to go like i was actually
going to cancel and not go because of
everything that was going on but
um
it was i just had to go if i didn't go i
feel felt like i'd be miserable
and just upset with myself um and i
trusted myself and nothing happened and
i was safe
can you share one of these signs that
you've received one of these guides or
something that's signaled to you
something on set so um
this was all in alignment which with
alignment to me my definition of
alignment is that i'm at the right place
at the right time i'm doing exactly what
i should be doing and it works
creatively
and it hits the goals of what i'm
looking to do is which is leave people
touch moved and inspired
and tell very important stories
uh so this was during the pandemic i was
in la
and uh it was a series of things that
happened that led me there to this
particular project that i'm in
post-production on now
uh of the screenwriter of the hearts of
men the project i mentioned said that
there was a buddy of his that i need to
meet um
and
his name is ron mccant awesome you know
writer out of orange county
and um
he was running this uh these town hall
meetings on zoom with everything that
was happening after what happened with
george floyd
and his goal um
is to uh just empower people of color
and educate and um he was already doing
this and when we talked we're trying to
figure out
what how what what can i bring to the
table how can i help and after
brainstorming
you know we
basically came up with this hbcu tour
because what we realize is that um
you can see people of color in front of
the screen but what's really important
is people of color behind the screen and
changing that and it starts at the
college level
i feel that it starts at the college
level
and
mentoring
and sharing those tools so
um
for a period of several months we had
these zooms where we'd have uh either it
would be all
female
group
or it would be a panel of you know brown
and black people um sharing their
experiences and us inviting the howards
the spelmans the tuskegee schools
um and just educating you know what we
do and how to be successful internship
programs
uh i felt like we built a really good
dynamic
um
information hub but also an execute hub
because we can give all the information
in the world but people need something
to execute with so we had built a
program for people to learn visual
effects through a company called chicken
bone um dylan darren l segundo but
they're worldwide the head of the
company is el segundo and he's become a
great friend and he developed a a
program where
people can intern or learn about vfx
because most people don't know about vfx
and we found
other individuals that were showing how
to be able to get a project um
to produce a project that's coming out
of afi just really high level you know
things so one of the people i worked
with was a young lady that had went to
usc she had graduated and she was
president of a film club
and
one day she mentioned to me like hey
there's a young man in new york that
wants to tell this story um he's been
trying to get it done before
[Music]
pandemic happened and this was i want to
say
we're in 2022 so this was in
uh early 2021
i want to say late 2020 maybe early 2021
um and i said yeah i'd love to you know
hear more about it because you know the
kind of work that i'm making and you
know she mentioned it was a short would
you be open to it and i said well it
just really depends on the message
and um when i got the script i
recognized the writer's name you know
the writer director's name and this
gentleman i had met
two years ago um because there was
another young man from nyu
um so the young lady that had introduced
me went to usc but this young man that
wrote the script went to nyu grad and um
i had met him two years ago because a
friend of mine had done a film called my
nephew emmett that won um i think it was
the it was either the student oscars or
he won the oscars as a short and it was
a very impressive short round you know
emmett till um and it was playing at in
somewhere in uh williamsburg
and i went to the screening and there
were other films that were playing
and he introduced me to this young man
and he was west indian and he had this
amazing short that he did and i was
blown away i was like wow and i from
that point i just kind of tracked him
and what he was up to his career
and then um i had saw that he was had a
fellowship at sundance through black
house very dear friends with the founder
of black house and i always go there
when i'm at the sundance film festival
and i was like wow you know i'm
following his journey i'm so happy for
him and then he ended up working um well
he didn't end up working he ended up
getting like um
i think jack daniels award um i don't
remember how much money he received but
omari hardwick had given him
the check he was the presenter and i had
worked with omari on a film that had
gone to sundance so
um all these things that kind of
happened
and um when i saw his name on the script
i'm like oh my god like this is an
opportunity to work with him and i've
been tracking him for so long just
um
part of it is strategy and part of it is
just if i see something and i see his
name somewhere like then i look a little
bit more so it was organically two
um and when that came to me and the
pieces were kind of together um
i'm like wow you know like i'd love to
work with him and after reading the
story the story was based off a
documentary
a pbs documentary that was made it was
inspired it wasn't based off the
document it was inspired off the
documentary and the documentary had done
really well and it dealt with a young
you know uh a young 16 year old uh
man
that was incarcerated as an adult for a
crime that he
he was i
i want to say he did he was going to
commit but he didn't commit it and um
he was forced by the abuser to do this
crime it wasn't his choice um and it was
very hard to watch that documentary you
know it makes you want to cry and you
know you get upset with the system and i
felt it was my responsibility to help
tell the story and get behind uh the
writer director and the story
and it just aligned with my vision my
goals um and the fact that i've been is
tracking this young man so it just made
sense i had read the script i had some
notes on it i had shared it with the
team they had notes on it so i knew it
still needed work but i knew i wanted to
work with him and i liked the premise of
the story which is why i got behind it
and
this was like the end of 2020 beginning
of 2021 i want to say and we shot it
november of 2021 so now it's in post
um
and
probably the end of this year
you know or late or fall of this year
we'll begin our festival submission you
know with this project